hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're
gonna be working with react and I'm
trying to get this project ready that
we've been working on for months and
months since the beginning of the year
and so I just have a bunch of things on
my list that need finished up some of
them are just minor changes other ones a
little bit bigger we're just going to
see how many we can get through today
for those of you who are new to the
stream this is me doing my daily work as
a front-end developer so it's is not
rehearsed we're gonna make mistakes I
don't always know what what I'm gonna do
going in like today I'm not exactly sure
how much will cover it I do my best to
try to explain things as I go along feel
free to ask any questions if you have
questions split things up by Pomodoro
sessions so we'll do a 25-minute session
of code where I won't really look at the
live chat that much and then I'll take a
five minute break I'll catch up on the
chat answer a few questions and then
we'll go back and forth between the 25
minutes of code and five minutes of
questions until I feel like stopping and
then I'll finish up with all the
questions before we end the stream so
let me explain very quickly what we're
working on and what I hope to accomplish
at least in the first Pomodoro session
so we are working on a react website it
will be the main website for a small
university that I work for and we are
getting data from WordPress and we're
pulling it into this react website with
graph QL and a REST API what else we
doing that's that's good enough for now
we're not really gonna work with any
back-end stuff so I don't need to
explain everything if you're interested
in that you
check out some of the previous shows or
ask me and I'll explain it later on
before today we're going to be working
mainly just on the front end side of
things with react some components some
styles we are using material material
you I it's a library of react components
to give your app a material design style
I did recently upgrade to the latest
version of material UI so it's version 3
so this is all the the newest stuff and
yeah let's get started so I'm gonna
switch over so y'all can see what's on
my screen and I'm gonna make this a bit
bigger okay let me know if that font
size needs to be larger than that I'll
try to shrink down everything as much as
possible
alright so almost everything that you
see on my screen is available in the
github repo I did make just a few
changes that I didn't push the github
yet and that's simply right here you can
see with this blue bar I added in some
grid containers and a button so that's
what we're gonna start out now we're
gonna add in a few more buttons make
sure they link to the right place and
that'll be the the starting point we're
in the footer jas component so the link
to the github repo is in the description
if you'd like to follow along I can also
start this end rock server
let me start before Midori session and
then I'll start and rock I can't
remember how to start Angra let's see if
it's in there we go can never remember
the command because I always just have
it ready so let's start that up now I'm
gonna copy and paste this link in the
live chat if you click this link or copy
and paste it into your browser you'll be
able to see the website that we're
working on as we're working on it
one other big change that has happened
since the last time I
I streamed was that I tried out Google
App Engine so I had a few phone calls
with some representatives from Google
cloud and they kind of filled me in on
some of the options that I had for
hosting this and so I decided to try out
App Engine instead of using now for
deployment and hosting I really like it
it's very fast it'll consolidate all my
billing into one place instead of having
multiple companies so I think I'm gonna
go with that so I haven't switched over
the URL yet from now to App Engine but
that will be happening soon so I'll
probably do probably do some work with
that on a live stream when it gets
closer to the time to launch which
should be pretty soon I had a lot of
meetings recently with changes to the
website so the launch will happen within
the next few weeks unless I have more
meetings and something else changes I
suppose okay let me let me double check
okay so that seems like it's working for
you all and I want to show you on the
for those of you who can't open that
link I do want to show you on the screen
what this is gonna look like so we're
working on the footer right now you see
I had some lorem ipsum with so it's
called bacon ipsum it's lorem ipsum
filler text with the names of various
meats in there so I'm replacing that
with this you see I've already put in
the address and this is properly
formatted right so according to what
schema.org says so that that can get
picked up by search engines and display
properly all right so we've done that
and now I just want to put in a few
buttons to request the info and then
over here I'm just going to
put a very short list of some other
links probably links to like the privacy
policy and things like that you know
your standard stuff that most websites
have in the footer that's what we're
gonna have for now we'll have some
different stuff in there after we launch
most likely we're gonna maybe have a
small contact form but for now this is
what we're gonna go with for for launch
so I need two other buttons it's gonna
mimic what we have here requested info
apply and visit and really I'm gonna
have the same set up here of request
info being large and then these two
buttons being half the width so we got
requested fill in there it it just the
button just has the appearance it's not
linked up to anything yet so we'll have
to put that in but for now let's just
get everything in here and then we can
work on the rest of it I'll probably
want to Center this inside of here
otherwise it's gonna look a little bit
odd so let's get the buttons in there
and then we can work on on centering
things also I've been developing things
kind of in this view mobile first view
so I'm probably gonna stick with this
although it may be hard to see on the
stream so I am gonna kind of toggle back
and forth just so that I get an idea of
how this will look on a mobile
environment as well so for now I'm gonna
just do min on this section so you all
can see it but let's go in here and so
we have this grid item in material UI it
comes with this grid system these grid
components right so we have this grid
container for the footer and then within
it we're splitting the footer up into
three sections on a large screen on a
small screen each section takes up the
full width right so within that middle
section of the three we've put another
container
and then we have another grid item this
first one is going to take up the full
width all the time but we're gonna make
two more that are gonna take up the full
width on a small screen but on a larger
screen that's only going to take up half
the width all right that's how we're
gonna get the buttons so that'll be one
button on the top and then two buttons
underneath we also want to make sure
that we pass in the correct info so this
is a component that we've created called
this inverted button and that basically
just gives us these styles but crui does
have a button they didn't when we
started this project but they now have a
button called an outlined button it's a
button variant on that the button
component i I'm not I kind of like the
style better maybe just because I'm used
to it because we've been using it so
their outline button is a little bit
different so I've decided you just stick
with our inverted button for now and at
some point maybe we'll switch it up but
this works for now we've already created
this component so it'll be less work to
just use this than to try to modify the
styles of the material UI button so
let's go to that component just for a
second to see what we need to pass in
actually we can check here because we
have these buttons yep here we are so we
can pass in an href a title yep that
works let's do that then I'm gonna just
grab these from here I'm sorry I need to
change my my playlist here the
throwbackthursday playlist on Spotify is
playing me like all these slow jams and
I've got nothing against slow jams but
they're just not great to code to like I
need energy right you know say so let's
let's switch it up
okay
so let me add these I want to add it
here to this button because I'm gonna
copy and paste all this and the more
complete this one is nonetheless I have
to modify everything so I'm gonna change
this to just include this like is there
they're all gonna have different
different values for these so let's just
leave it like this for now and we're
gonna copy the whole grid at some point
it might not be a bad idea to pull all
this data in from from our API from
WordPress but for now I'm just trying to
get this launched I don't have a problem
with hard coding this right now
eventually it'd be great to have as much
as possible be editable from within our
CMS but that means that way if anything
needs to change like for the text
content we don't actually have to change
our code which is a good thing
that's a good goal to have but not
necessary before launch so let me change
these you double-check and see what we
have
okay apply and then visit so this one's
gonna say apply and this one will say
visit and we're gonna add in here so
that small screens let's have this take
up six right so six columns which would
be half
we'll see how this looks I think a small
screen will be a good place to have this
breakpoint but if it's too narrow then
we can always go up and say that that
break will take place at the medium size
and I'll leave out the titles and the HS
for now because we're just trying to get
things to look right and that's just a
matter of copying and pasting I can
always do that later let's see all right
that's good let's save that and then
check it out - yes okay cool
so we now have these buttons definitely
need to make some adjustments though
this doesn't look good at all right so
let me double check how it looks on a
small screen - yeah not great doesn't
look good so let's change this a bit and
you know what let's go in here first
we'll try to make some changes in dev
tools this will enable us to change
things just a bit more click quickly
than we could with our code and we won't
have to keep flipping back and forth
between screens so I wanted to double
check and make sure that this was set to
display flex it is which I figured it
was and I like to see how we can do this
so we can go with let's try flex see
justify content and see what this is
gonna do no align items
okay that's not doing anything either
mm-hmm all right let's try this display
flex the line items there we go okay so
usually they have to play with Flex box
a little bit I'm still you know I'm not
I don't use it enough and I'm not that
good with it to just know exactly what I
need at first so what we did here was we
set this div which art is our container
div for this button all right we said
this div to be display flex and then we
could use the flex box positioning for
this so we set justify content to Center
you see that move the button right into
the center okay so let's do something
similar with these but what we're gonna
do is I'm gonna say display flex we're
justify content and for this one we're
gonna say flex n and for this one yeah
actually this one works as is we don't
need to say anything all right but what
we do need to say all right before I get
too far ahead of myself let's go back
and add these styles in in here so what
I want to do is
hmm let me add in some some styles here
so let's say am I actually using white I
think I am yeah I am okay I'm will get
rid of it then so let's just say Flex
container we're gonna create the style
called Flex container and this is just
gonna give it a display whoops
flex I need to put that okay so if
you've never done styles like this with
react basically these are very similar
to normal CSS but it's in the form of a
JavaScript object so the syntax is going
to look a little different we use camel
case right and then we have to put most
of our values here in quotation marks
but we can take this then this Flex
container class and add it on to our
grids and I'm gonna use my multiple
cursors here to say bring your class
name and we're gonna say classes dot
Flex container and let's save that and
we should see let me refresh this to get
rid of what we did over here
okay I don't know why that was so slow
but should work now
okay
so if we inspect those containers they
should all have display flex yep
so this display flex on this one on this
one and on this one and now we can add
our other styles in here so what I want
to do now is we're gonna have this this
class name but also I'm gonna use the
style tag this is just going to
demonstrate another way you can do
styles and react and basically it's an
inline style but we're still going to
use that JavaScript object syntax here
so we're going to say style we're going
to put double curly bracket so the first
curly bracket is means that hey we're
going to do some JavaScript so we're
telling react we're about to do some
JavaScript and then that second bracket
is object notation right it's going to
say this is an object so within that
object we're gonna have key value pairs
just like a normal object right and our
our key in this case is gonna be justify
content and then our value is gonna be
Center I think that's what we need
Center I'm gonna copy and paste this
down here to this grid as well and for
this one we needed to say Flex end ok
now this should give us now our
alignment that we had before hopefully
yeah yeah see so this gives us our
alignment and so normally so if I have a
style that I want apply to multiple
components it makes sense to put it down
here and add it as a class if I have a
style that I'm going to use once and
it's just one thing then I usually do it
in line like this if I were to apply
let's say two or three like three or
more things to a component even if I'm
only gonna apply it to one one component
or one element of probably making a
class as well it can get pretty messy if
you start to put a lot of stuff in line
like this so for me for the way I do
things this makes sense if we end up
adding in some other stuff we'll just
move it down it's not a big deal it's
you know copy and paste so this is how I
like to work there's there's not really
a consensus on what is the absolute best
way to do styles in react right now so I
use a variety of ways usually on the
same project even within the same
component and until there's some
consensus about the best way which
honestly may never happen I'm just gonna
keep trying out different ways and doing
what works for my projects okay just
want to let you all know if you haven't
puttin anything in the live chat and I
have it read it I'm I'm gonna check the
live chat here in about six and a half
minutes
okay so just hang in there just a few
more minutes okay so next step then is
we don't want that this still looks
terrible right we don't want this so we
need to put some space in here so we
need some padding between there let's
try eight pixels and if that's too tight
we'll jump we'll bump it up to 16 pixels
and just see how that looks after that
then we're going to make it so that
these buttons
align properly with this top
so basically like the width of this top
button should be the same as the width
of both these buttons and the padding in
between them all combined if that
doesn't make sense right out well once
you see it so again let's just test this
out here in dev tools first and make
this a bit bigger might be too small so
in dev tools let's take this button here
and let's add so let's go to origin I'm
just gonna add 8 pixels in here and then
down here let's add 8 pixels and we'll
do the same thing for this button and
we'll just see how it looks first then
we'll just okay let's zoom out actually
I like that
I like how that looks let's switch it up
for a second and see how it looks here
it's gonna be weird see so we're gonna
have to put on a media query here and
switch up how they're aligned but for
now that the at least the spacing
between them is acceptable okay all
right so that looked good so I think if
we go with just a standard 8 pixels
around all of our buttons that'll work
and fortunately we already have a class
on all our buttons right this inverted
button dart class so I'm just gonna add
to that class a margin of 8 pixels
remember our comma and we save that that
should work I'm not gonna check because
it's I'm like 99% sure that'll work
okay now we want to make sure that our
buttons are all aligned like in terms of
a width right so to do that is there's
some different ways we could do it let's
see what this looks like just we'll play
around a little bit see what this will
look like so let's take this button and
let's just I don't think it's gonna look
good like this but I just want to try it
right so let's go with with 100% oh
that's huge
okay too big too big mm-hmm
so we could go with a fixed width or a
percentage with I guess it'll probably
be easier if we go to the fixed width
let's see what we have up here I mean we
obviously achieve this up here I just
don't remember how we did it
okay so I did go with the fix with all
right well let's just try that
let's just let's try fix with so we can
try with with 200 pixels okay actually
that's that's not too bad in terms of
this working here so if we had 200
pixels as the width here each one of
these buttons would need to be 100
pixels but since we have 16 pixels of
margin in here we'd have to subtract
that so that would be 8 off of each
button so we want to make each about 92
pixels and that should that should work
so let's do this then
on our button itself let's go just make
sure I'm on the right button here on our
buttons I'm gonna do our multiple
cursors again to select all of them at
once and we're gonna do style equals
we're gonna use our double brackets here
and let's say with is gonna equal 92
pixels so these two are gonna stay 92
and for this one I'm gonna switch it up
and say 200 and now when I save that
hopefully it works well let's see did it
work
he said lined up yeah I just lined up
cool that worked okay so we have all of
our buttons here nice all lined up
properly let's check it out for mobile
it's gonna look bad so this still looks
bad so we need to switch it up for
mobile which is going to be basically
we're just going to work with some media
queries here and what is this pixel -
let's let's drop down I mean a pixel -
is a pretty wide phone let's go to a
very narrow phone as if it works for a
very narrow fund will know that it'll
work for a little bit of a wider phone
if we're going to drop down here this is
only 320 pixels and across and width and
that's this the narrowest phone that I
know of right so I I don't know at least
the last time I checked there was no
other viewport than at it was more
narrow than that so if it works here at
a word for everything so given that we
may be able to do really what we could
do is is keep this same alignment even
on a on a phone that might be the
easiest thing to do so that we would
actually have that yeah let's let's try
that here my timer just went off so I'm
gonna go back to the live chat in just a
second
but if we get rid of this
did I mess that up
it's just for 12 oops yeah that was not
what I wanted to do what I want to do
work I want to make this six yeah and
then get rid of this okay there we are
there we go okay so now we have these
buttons here there's still some issues I
think with spacing between the sections
but not bad not sure if I like it
standard either but I think it's it's
okay for now it's it's decent okay let
me put on my five-minute timer now I'm
gonna go to the chat get through as many
things as I can
Abdul Rahman says hi Jesse thank you for
sharing your live video with us I get my
motivation from your videos because
you're showing us how to how a developer
works and gets into some code issues and
mistakes Thanks oh you're welcome
I'm glad this is this is helpful for you
and helps helps motivate you see Ahmed
says what do I need to learn before
starting in reacts HTML CSS JavaScript
and so at least the basics of those
right the more you know about HTML CSS
and JavaScript the easier react is gonna
be but you certainly don't need to be an
expert first buhbuh so of says hi from
is there by John sorry if I'm
mispronouncing any of that but how's it
going thanks for watching Munn griffin
says thank you I've been watching your
videos oh you're welcome thanks for
watching
those Cosi says only basic JavaScript
then you can start react yes yeah yeah
for sure just learn you know if you want
to know the bare minimum to start react
is just basics of JavaScript C aki says
what's free code camp free code camp is
a nonprofit organization and our goal is
to help people learn how to code for
free so free code camp org has a bunch
of lessons you can take to learn how
code online we have this YouTube channel
with a ton of content we have a medium
publication which lots of blogs and
tutorials there we have a forum where
you can ask questions we also have a
podcast and there are free code camp
meetup groups all over the world so
there are a lot of different ways that
free code camp is is helping people to
learn how to code and actually there's
going to be a free code camp hackathon
in San Francisco at the end of October
so you could check that out as well if
you're in San Francisco I think is gonna
be an online portion of the hackathon so
even if you're not there in San
Francisco you can still participate so
check that out I don't remember what the
link is but if you look it up free code
camp hackathon I'm sure it'll come up
Nilesh says do you have the correct
folder structure for react I don't I
don't really know as far as I know
there's not a standard react folder
structure maybe I'm wrong about this but
it kind of depends on what you use to
bootstrap your react application alright
so if I'm using next js' like like I am
usually we have this pages folder and
you wouldn't normally have a pages
folder if you let's say use create react
app you may have a folder that would
save views instead of pages you may not
have it at all so you know this is the
structure that I use if I'm using next
JFS
let's see AB Abby gist says thank you
for this you're welcome welcome thanks
for watching
Nitin says this channel changed my life
can you say my name yeah Nitin Verma so
hopefully I'm saying that correctly
please let me know if I'm not and I'll
try to say it correctly next time but
I'm really glad that this channel has
helped you out hopefully has changed
your life for the better I'm assuming
that Andrew says I've really enjoyed
using a motion for CSS and J s I'd
really love to help with some
contributions on this project Jessie but
I'm a little intimidated by open source
Andrew you know check out the issues on
our github repo and see if there's an
issue that maybe you think you could
handle and if you have any questions
just comment on that issue I'll do my
best to help you through it and you know
see if you if you'd like to contribute
and that goes for anybody else if you
see something on the project where you
you'd like to work on just you know let
me know you check out the github repo
and you know I'll try to make it as easy
as possible for you to contribute DeLeon
says thank you for sharing that
knowledge you're welcome
Brandon says first time tuning in for
stream have been going through some of
the pre-recorded videos this looks like
a valuable experience to see the process
in action
oh cool well I hope it is valuable for
at least some of you so I appreciate you
saying that
so sophie-anne
sorry if I'm mispronouncing that that
says what is your style syntax since
it's not CSS well this is JSX
is the the syntax that we use in our
react components and I'm not even sure
what exactly the name is for doing CSS
like this and in Deus Ex is it's yes I
don't know if it's CSS
in j/s or I don't really know to be
honest with you if somebody knows how
what's the name of this is let me know I
just I know how it works I just don't
know what it's called
[Music]
Robin says sir I know a little more
JavaScript cannot learn react yeah if
you know some JavaScript certainly you
can you can start learning react see
groovy tubers says can you also upload a
video on competitive programming I don't
have a video on competitive programming
I don't really know that much about it
but if if somebody out there has some
good content on that you know get in
touch with somebody from our probably
like Quincy or beau from free code camp
and let them know what your content is
and maybe it can be put on our channel
as well okay I'm gonna go back to the
code now for let me check the time okay
yeah let's do one more Parliament Oreo
session we might not even do a full
Pomodoro session we're just going to try
to finish this up a bit and then I'll
answer some questions because really
actually I've put in most most of the
time I need to today in the office so I
can go home since let's see okay so for
now this is okay looking not a hundred
percent thrilled with it but like I said
we want to launch soon so the goal isn't
get things perfect the goal is get
things acceptable right there are
certain key places on the site that we
really wanted to look very nice but then
there are other areas that we can work
on even after the launch the footer is
one of those areas where a lot of people
are never even going to see it so this
does not need to be perfect right now so
we just have one more section left that
doesn't have real content yet and that's
this section of the footer so I would
like to have this on another screen let
me pull this so on the current site
which is Franciscan ddu the footer has
links for Kwanzaa
the privacy policy directions
non-discrimination statement and
consumer information so it probably
wouldn't be a bad idea to put in the
same links over here I do want to
double-check and see if we have any of
those links here no we don't okay yeah
so I think we definitely want to put
those links in the footer are like
legally those are some pretty important
links so do this I think I'm just going
to do a regular unordered list I'm I'm
not even gonna try to check out the
materialized components for this because
I'm not trying to do anything fancy I
just need a list so let's go to our code
here in our footer and this section and
let's put in a ul oops why didn't that
automatically make you all and let's
make an ally okay and then within our
there we go within our ally we want a
link you know probably gonna use let's
use link tags and I don't think I have
the links here I don't let's import our
link tag which I think I've in here
I don't
I need to find a place where I'm using
this link tag maybe here no
all right let's see
how did you
there we are so you're gonna import link
from next link so what this is gonna do
just full I don't know why I imported
this and then I'm not using it let me
get rid of that done so what this is
gonna do by using this link tag is it's
gonna let us prefetch content that way
if the user ends up clicking on this
we'll just go on here
mess this up because I don't have the
closing tag so if you use your ends up
clicking on one of these links the load
time is going to be pretty much
instantaneous because the data will
already be loaded in in the background
so I like to use these link tags
whenever I can and let's also make sure
we grab so we need an href so all we
need
I actually think we'll need more than
that
so because of the way we're doing
routing we need more than just the href
on our link tag so I'm gonna work
properly so I'm gonna go to this drawer
item and see what else we need there we
are
so we need this stuff and let's add this
in now link and then within the link
we're gonna put an a tag
hey and we'll just give it some text
let's just say what's that first one
contact
okay so one of these the HF is gonna be
like what actually shows up in the URL
or in the in the URL bar right the next
thing is gonna be when we say as that's
gonna be what actually gets put into
like the router like where are we gonna
get this data from so for href I'm gonna
have to look contact okay so in this
case the HF it's really easy we just do
contact right the contact page but let
me go - let's go to this drawer menu
let's pull this over so you can see the
as URL is gonna look more like this
right so let's just copy and paste that
so under our page type we're gonna say
about pages and the ID that we want to
get for that Content ID is going to be
contact hey I don't know if this is
hundred percent correct right now but
I'm just gonna use it just as an example
just let's see how it looks and item
it's not defined without even it whoops
and we don't want we just want to say
prefect prefetch is true right so you
don't necessarily have to say prefetch
equals true you could just put prefetch
but I believe for newer versions of reax
you're gonna want to put equals true i
can't remember the details i just
vaguely remember learning somewhere
along the line that this is the way we
want to do it now so that's what I'm
gonna do
all right so we have our contact and it
gives us it's giving us the wrong thing
it is okay
why is it doing this I have these
backwards so let's switch these up so
this needs to say as yeah this makes
more sense so so we want to get this
contact content but we won't put it as
this this URL alright let's let's save
that and they go back here and make sure
we're getting the right yeah now it'll
say contact I don't know if this will
work
hey it works wonderful so I did get it
right let's check our console and see if
it is actually you all cannot appear to
the cinema P okay let's get rid of this
typography or at least yeah let's get
rid of typography for here cuz that was
causing an error and let's refresh that
see what we get now Dave cannot appear a
descendent of P I guess we can get rid
of our typography component or else here
okay let's see what we get now all right
cool
not too bad we don't have errors here
let's check our network and see I'm
going to try to see where that's weird
usually I can see what pages are trying
to be pre-loaded
oh you know what we're on devmode so
it's not gonna preload
I can't test it out now so on the
versions of the site that I actually
have like live at a URL then I could see
if this would work so I'm not gonna
check it now because I have to deploy
this you can see some more styles are
messed up now but what we can do though
is just put in so where I had this
footer sections and then
four sections footer text alright let's
let's do that actually I mean it'd be
easier to copy and paste this so let's
bring this back in just for a second so
I can pull this class name out and then
now let's see what I can get away with
here if I put this on on the grid
container let's see what it will do if I
get away with putting it that high up
and it still works yeah it worked
awesome okay let's see we still have
some odd styling going on here because
we have the a tag in the list so let's
just add in a few more yeah
so these allies we're gonna copy and
paste these and because we need let me
see need four more of these one two
whoops three four okay so we need four
of those
see how that looks I'm checking my time
while I'm over here alright about 12
minutes okay alright there we are
so here's our list and we need to change
see
all right so on rul let's go with style
list-style:none see if that works
they have to say list style type nope
that works cool so we got rid of those
little circles and then now we also need
you know what let's see if this will
work on the UL we may have to put it
down lower like on the a tag but if we
can get it to work on the UL that'll be
great
so let's go color and FFF is gonna be
white see if that'll work for us look
like it did not work let's inspect just
to make sure yep so it's being
overridden by by this okay
so we are going to need to but I guess
it doesn't matter the footer is on every
page now so let's get rid of that and
instead on our a tags we're gonna need
to put our color there
and actually since we have this color
white I guess we could just use that so
on all of our a tags let's drop down and
put class last name now I would say this
normally I wouldn't hard code a list
like this out we probably just want to
do it one time map over in an array that
would give us all this informations like
an array of objects and then only have
this markup you know once right and it
would map over but for now since there's
not that many items I'm just going to do
it like this all right eventually it
will be mapped over data that we're
getting from from our graph UO API no
area okay so our class name and I don't
know what those I want classes white
there we are and that will show up
better mmm I mean it does show up better
but it's definitely not great let's see
what this is all right font size is okay
but it looks like maybe it could use a
bit bigger font weight so let's go with
font weights 400 see what that gives us
all right 400 is definitely more
readable yeah let's go with 400 so here
where we have our class name classes
white we're also gonna say style and
we're gonna say font weight and we're
just gonna say 400 we don't need to put
that in quotation marks because it's
just a number right so that that'll work
if it had let's say any type of string
any type of characters that were letters
we would have to put it in quotation
marks now we close that out with our
double brackets hit save there it is
just to kind of get an idea I'm gonna
change a few of these so that it's not
just contact because it looks weird
right now
privacy pure these yeah that's how you
spell privacy
[Music]
directions it's just a few just to see
okay alright not bad
there's too much padding on the top I do
want to see why that's there it looks
like that's on the UL itself so let's
get rid of that and do we need it on the
bottom too
no we don't really need that on the
bottom I think we're fine with the
normal amount of padding Oh what
happened here okay something happened
here let's fix that as well
Zach
Hey
okay so we don't want it on there okay
all right so for some reason
footer sections so we've given this
container div just can't contain a grid
that maybe that was a mistake I know
yeah you know what this needs to be
outside of here then see what it does
not yeah we are okay yeah so we needed
that to be outside of the main container
div so if you didn't see would just
happen
we had margin here because this section
was actually inside of the container div
for all these sections and that
container div had a margin here of 16
pixels so once we moved it outside of
that container it was free to take up
the full width right okay now let's get
rid of that and it should be looking
pretty good so on our UL let's just add
one more style here and this is gonna be
margin:0 and if that takes care of our
problem great we're good okay so the
margin is knocked off the bottom this is
a lot thinner probably would want to
make this margin a bit bigger if I was
like really trying to make this perfect
I would want it to match this margin on
the top but for now I'm okay with it
yeah so that's pretty good what I would
need to do here obviously is put in the
correct text and all the correct info
for the links for these things in the
footer and I might think about maybe
centering this but doing it in a way
where it would still be straight along
this edge right if that makes sense
other than that that's fine for the
footer maybe you can see like this needs
to be up on the same line as the rest of
this street address so the zip code
needs to be up yeah these links need the
the right URLs as well now button get
cool let me take all right about three
minutes and this time I'm going to
commit this and then push it to github
so if you're not familiar with how that
works and github then I'll try to
explain what I'm doing as we go along so
we're going to get status just to see
what's changed so as expected we've only
changed this one component or footer ojs
component so we're gonna do a git add
and I'm just going to put in a period
and that'll just add everything which in
this case is just one one file you can
actually put in the name of the file if
you just want to add one among many
files one or two or however many you
want and then I'm gonna say yarn cm
actually first I'm going to yarn unit u
so I'm gonna update our snapshots for
our unit tests just to make sure that
what we've changed isn't messing
anything up so you can see the index
test j s has been updated because we
have we're using this footer component
in index so if we hadn't have updated it
when we tried to run all of our tests to
make sure that our changes didn't break
anything it would have failed the test
right so that's why we're running that
first now I'm gonna do another git add
because our snapshot has been updated so
you can see here our snapshot for index
dot JSP Yorn cm which is basically just
like running a git commit
with a but this is just gonna walk us
through how to craft a really nice
commit message so we're gonna say we're
gonna add a new feature right and I'm
gonna skip the scope we're only dealing
with one component it's it's okay it'll
be obvious what component was changed
and now I'm gonna say that we to add
buttons and linked lists to footer just
basically describing what we did right
we're gonna say we're gonna do this like
present tense right so let's all you say
add button is a linked list of footer
let's hit enter I'm not gonna put a
longer description right now because
it's not very complicated what we did if
it was more complex it would be a good
idea to put a long description there we
didn't break anything so we're gonna go
no with that and we didn't have any
issues as far as I remember that dealt
with this footer so I'm gonna say no to
that as well if we did have an issue we
would just reference that issue number
and then it would automatically put a
little note in that issue with a
reference to this commit or if we had
said fix and then put the issue number
it would have automatically closed that
issue for us which is pretty awesome so
you can see that we passed all our unit
tests we also passed our end-to-end
tests and now we can just do a get push
and that's gonna push all our changes up
to our github repository so now you all
can check out that repo and everything
that we've done today will be there
obviously need to perfect that a bit
need to finish out adding in some data
but the basic layout right the mark-up
is gonna remain the same okay so now I'm
gonna take the rest of the stream to
answer questions and let me just show
you I'm gonna show you briefly I haven't
showed it for a long time what I'm doing
here so I'm going to add content to
footer I estimated that this will take
me to Palm adoro sessions and we just
spent two
Dora sessions on that so I'm gonna say
it took two out of two this is in my
Trello board right and now actually be
honest I'm gonna leave this in in
progress since I still have a bit of
content to put in there probably if I
didn't do it live I could have got it
all in but as I'm explaining things it
does take a bit longer so this is going
to be in my column of in progress right
once we're done with it we can move it's
completed if it needs testing I'll move
it to testing first okay but this is my
Trello board and that's all the stuff
that needs to be done assigned to the
people that need to do it my to-do list
my ready for dev stuff this is all stuff
that I really want to get done this week
and then here's my completed list in
each one of these that I'm working on
has estimates for how long it will take
and then once I'd actually do it I say
here's how long it actually did take and
these are broken down by Pomodoro
sessions okay and then not only that but
then also here I have my project
timesheet so we can see you today's date
August 30th which is my daughter Gemma's
birthday she just turned seven today and
then I have my time which I'm a little
bit behind my on how much time I've been
spending but let's just say we took
about 50 minutes right to Pomodoro
sessions for this and see to add content
to footer so I'm keeping track of every
day how many how much time I spend now
this doesn't take into account things
like meetings which did you take up a
lot of time or any correspondence for
the site and so I'm not perfect with
this so usually this is this estimate is
less time than it really takes but so
far on this project it's over 250 hours
of work like I said - meetings and
usually like some research time and
stuff like that so that's how I keep
track of things for my projects I do
this for all of my projects and
all right so let's go back to the live
chat I'm gonna scroll back up to where I
left off so if you have any other
questions right now feel free to put
them in the live chat now and I'll try
to get to everything this toughest is hi
from India hey how's it going thanks for
watching
Phillips is under some view how
different between view and react react I
haven't used view before so I don't
really know how different view and react
are so sorry has anybody used you and
react and can give us a comparison of
you know how how similar or different
they are
Marcio sorry if I'm pronouncing that
wrong but says I was just checking how
to contribute on open-source but I
couldn't find any videos for beginners
you have any recommendations Thanks
you know what off the top of my head I
can't think of any videos I'm pretty
sure I have seen some out there though
on how to contribute mmm yeah there's
got to be some I'm surprised there's not
one on the free code camp YouTube
channel to be honest with you so if you
haven't searched through free code camp
try it tried that Conrad asked if I've
tried style components yes I have you
styled components on a react native
project that I was working on a few
months ago I I kind of like styled
components it's a little bit different
so I'm not I'm not great with style
components yet but it's something I
would like to work more with fuzzy end
says thanks for your helpful tips you're
welcome
Thanks thanks for saying that thanks for
watching
ultra vid says I'm totally new to coding
but I want to learn more I know a little
HTML alright cool well that's a good
place to start I definitely recommend
going to free code camp dot org and
checking out the lessons and it
start you out HTML move into CSS and
then into JavaScript and and beyond so
if you want to learn more definitely
check that out Robert says when you make
a video about Redux in the future maybe
maybe if we use Redux I do have a video
on my youtube channel so I believe
there's a link to my youtube channel in
the description it's a if you search
Jessie why go on youtube you'll probably
find it but I have a video I think it's
react native live coding is the title of
the video is that what it is no you know
what that's not it
wow that is a video on my channel but
the one where I use Redux is on the free
code camp Channel if you search react
native and Redux you should see one of
my videos where we work with react
native and redux so check that out I may
do more in the future but for now you
can check that out and I think it was
maybe project 3 I think that's what it
was
let's see so so sofiane says thank you
as JSX style advantages on CSS there are
some advantages so if if what you're
creating with the Styles is just a
JavaScript object like I'll go I'll show
it again here on the screen then you can
do JavaScript right so so any
calculations you could normally do with
JavaScript functions whatever you could
do inside here and so you could do more
than you could normally with with CSS
more like dynamic things right
this show says please upload a video
about how to build programming logic I
don't have video about that the other
thing is to you know I'm one of many
contributors to free code camp so a lot
of this stuff like there may be videos
about this already on free code camp
that I don't even know about because we
have so much content here on the YouTube
channel colleague says please tell me
which website is best for learning HTML
CSS I'm new to coding in which language
I first have to learn check out free
code camp Ward and go through their HTML
and CSS lessons and see what you think
Robert also mentions code Academy yeah
that's that's also a good place to go
I've done there lessons as well the
latest music also recommends w3 schools
I I did use those back in the day I free
code camp and code Academy / w3 schools
to be honest with you the only advantage
of solo w3 schools is their lessons seem
to have a lot more reading at least they
used to a lot more reading and less
hands-on stuff so if you only have time
to read and not to actually type for
anything then there are things you could
read there I find that Mozilla developer
Network has more detailed information
which sometimes it's overwhelming if
you're starting out though but if you
wanted more details check them out
instead of w3 schools according to you
which programming language should I go
with first it for sure if you want to do
anything with front-end web development
go with JavaScript if you're not sure
what you want to do go with JavaScript
because it's so versatile and can be
used really for nearly anything that
you would want to use a purring
programming language for if you know
specifically what you want to do then
there may be another programming
language that is better suited to that
thing so for instance data science seems
to rely more on our Python same like
machine learning relies a lot on Python
if you want to work with like dotnet
framework stuff maybe you want to try
c-sharp if you're into WordPress or
Drupal you want to go with PHP right so
it depends on what you want to do but
just in general JavaScript is a good
thing to go with because you know if
you're doing anything on the web you're
probably going to need to know
JavaScript at some point okay Robert
also reiterated that mdn is a better
resource than w3 schools how you Excel
and which is good for app development it
depends on what you want to do if you
want to use react native to develop apps
then javascript is great if you want to
develop just iOS apps then maybe you
want to learn Swift if you want to
develop Android apps then you could
learn Java or Kotlin right so there are
a lot of options right I I like using
JavaScript with react native for mobile
apps because you just learn JavaScript
and you can make apps for Android or iOS
and that's especially good if you don't
really know what you want to specialize
in one or the other right you know
basically you get you get to do more
with learning only one language great
the vibe of says how do you start how do
you start learning programming I don't
know if you're asking in general like
how would you start learning programming
or you want to know them like my
personal story so I'm gonna say like in
general check out free code camp Torg I
know I keep saying that but it's a great
resource and I gotta get you a nice
intro to programming you know if you
want to do you could do you dasa T for
their courses you could do code Academy
for their stuff too free code camps not
the only resource out there but it is
free and I think it's quite good
let's see
and Emory says you can also use solo
learn okay so I have a new solo learn
but there's another I guess another
recommended resource there from Emory
now Embry also is asking what the name
of the software is and then later on
says Visual Studio code it is Visual
Studio code yeah Kalyug says HTML and
CSS are both interlinked right yeah so
HTML was like your your markup for the
page right so if you're building a house
HTML was is like your frame the wood
that you would use right the bricks for
the house CSS would be like the paint
right the decorations in your house
right so CSS makes HTML look nicer when
it's rendered in the browser to the user
right JavaScript would be like all the
moving parts and things like the
electricity in the house the thing that
opens your garage door the lights you
know the switches right that's what
makes things move it makes things happen
mistress's thank you for being live in
teaching us about react yeah no problem
thank you for watching
Kalyug says some websites only teach
HTML while others only CSS where to get
both at the same time yeah free code
camp for sure you can get both at the
same time it's gonna start with HTML and
then very quickly go into CSS as well
which is the right way to go I mean you
definitely want to learn HTML first
otherwise CSS doesn't really make much
sense because CSS is going to do things
it's gonna build on your HTML right CSS
targets HTML elements if you don't know
what any stimulant is it's gonna be
difficult to understand what CSS is
doing
David asks what's the framework you're
using for adding they get commit details
like that it's cold commit isn't so show
you my package.json there we go commit
is in I'll paste that in in the live
chat too
let's see Raul says what programming
language is this
it's JavaScript in particular it's a
JavaScript library called react and the
syntax is JSX
see done on J says hey Jessie how are
you not bad
pretty busy lately but not not too bad
so here's like a few minutes about me
since then on today s how I'm doing and
I haven't talked with you all for a
while so me personally been pretty busy
my my prolonged trip to Utah and then to
New York City threw me completely off my
schedule so finally getting back on my
schedule of getting good sleep and I'm
back on my diet and I need to get back
on my workout routine not quite back
there yet my wrist is still healing from
the surgery still hurts so I can't
really be able to work out like a
hundred percent and then I'm going to
try to get this website launched as fast
as I can I guess assuming that nothing
else happens like the terms of like
changes or anything that get requested
which keep happens keeps happening yeah
but that's just going on with me thanks
for asking are you doing deny J see
Brandon says what is your setup
hardware-wise I'm looking into
purchasing a new MacBook Air but I'm not
sure if it will be powerful enough for
web development and running Windows 10
and parallels the MacBook Air can
definitely do web development but I have
no idea about running Windows 10 as well
I don't really know about this my setup
in my office at work is a an iMac with
32 gigs of ram and it can handle two
external monitors you know plus the iMac
one and streaming and it's fine
I have a MacBook Pro that is also fine
with two external monitors for web
development but when I try to live
stream as well it gets a little sluggish
so but I've never tried to also run
Windows 10 on either of these machine
man mammy says I've learned so much just
watching then then I could do I really
appreciate your help so much so thank
you oh you're welcome thank you so much
for saying that Ilya says where do you
live
I live in the United States in Ohio so I
live in a small city called Steubenville
Ohio it's right on the eastern border of
Ohio and if you're familiar with
Pittsburgh which is a much bigger city
that's like the closest big city to me
I'm actually pretty close to to
Pittsburgh so if I Drive maybe about a
half hour drive I'm in Pittsburgh so not
sure if that helps you figure out where
I'm at but that's that's where I roll
hit says can we use Python for Android
application development I've never heard
of anybody using Python for that but it
may be as possible I've never never
really thought of it so usually for
Android if you're gonna do it like
completely native then you are gonna use
Java or Kotlin if you want to use
JavaScript you could use something like
ionic or react native dead zombie
recommends checking out the net ninja on
YouTube for beginners stuff so I'm
assuming like HTML Javascript CSS ok
Danko says it is possible to use Python
for Android application development but
it's not great not exactly what he said
but or with with ace he or she said I'm
not sure let's see Joseph says hello hey
Joseph house are going
Joseph s is that styled components or in
Oshin neither I'm not using either one
of those right now
and at least not on this project Kalyug
says you have cleared 99% of my doubts
thanks brother god bless love from India
oh thank you thank you I appreciate that
I'm glad I could help
world says how do you avoid getting
bored of coding hmm I don't know I mean
I like working on new things I like
coding mm-hmm other things too like
there are some specific tasks that are
really boring but coding in general I'm
always excited about because I can
always do like new things you know I
always try to use some new technique or
new technology and every time I do a new
project also like for boredom listening
to good Spotify playlist while I'm
trying to do the really boring stuff
helps caffeine helps stuff like that and
I generally like I like coding if
somebody really didn't like it I could
definitely see boredom being like a
bigger issue really it says tell me
about Python I don't know that much
about Python I've only done limited
stuff with it
the thing about Python that I remember
most is that there's not a lot of
special characters for the syntax like
for instance with JavaScript you're
using a lot of different brackets curly
brackets you know regular brackets
parenthesis and things like that with
Python a lot of your syntax is
determined by your indentation so you're
not gonna have a bunch of semicolons
everywhere in Python so that's it's kind
of interesting
I liked Python when I did use it but I
just don't have any need for it and most
of the work that I get paid for this
shawl says can you teach some advanced c
and c++ concepts I'm not I'm not really
qualified to teach C and C++ it's been
so long since I've used either one of
those languages and even when I did use
them it was just very basic
so you know maybe somebody else on the
tree code camp channel has already done
something about that or will do
something but I'm afraid that I wouldn't
be such a great teacher on those things
Gabriel says have you ever implemented
authentication and authorization with
graph QL as you did
I guess not really normally on projects
where we've had stuff like that with
graph QL
Harshit who watches the stream and
contributes frequently Harshit has
handled that so I can't really help with
that I wish I could world says why did
you go to Utah seems kind of random
okay so reactor rally is held in Salt
Lake City Utah so I was at the reactor
rally conference in Salt Lake City and
then went to right after that I went to
New York City for a free code camp Top
Contributor meetup that was held in in
Brooklyn in New York City so that's why
I was I was gone it was the longest I've
ever been away from from my family on my
own and so that was a little bit weird
it's a bit bit lonely but it was awesome
to meet a lot of other developers and
free code camp contributors it was cool
to see like I'd never been to Utah you
know let alone in Salt Lake City so it
was cool to see that area of the country
much different he would like the
climates different just the the
landscape the plan telling everything's
so different in Utah from where I am I
live and I haven't been in New York City
in 13 years so going back to New York
City was fun I had actually never been
to Brooklyn I had only been
and hadn't before so that was cool it
was really cool I walked I just spent a
lot of time walking around I walked
around a little bit in Salt Lake City
but I just spent like a whole day and
night just walking around New York just
checking everything out it was cool
let's see me kick says if you use the
CDN for react in only one js5 for all
the code how do you link all the
navigation links to the different parts
of that page hmm I don't know I mean I
guess if within your one file you broke
things out into different components
right but it was within one file like
you define multiple components in the
one file your navigation could probably
call those different components right
I'm not 100% sure but that's how I would
go about it I I suppose
Nikhil's says hi hey how's it going
Saurav says best books to learn coding
if you're trying to learn JavaScript I
would check out the you don't know Jay S
series which is available for free
online or you could get the book and the
eloquent JavaScript book which is also
available for free online or you can pay
for the print copy those those two books
you don't know jazz is really a series
of books but those two resources I've
been impressed with and I've read
through those I like them I don't know
if I finished eloquent JavaScript though
to be honest with you so or you don't
know Jay s to be honest with you I'm not
sure if I finish either one of those
those books other series of books but I
really liked what I did read over and
Nicki also said best book for react I've
never read any books about react so I
really don't know if anybody else has
any recommendations please you know put
them in the in the chat now or in the
comments to the video if you're watching
this later on
Mami's says if you are bored you do not
like it I do not get bored and can't do
it it makes you think and ponder yeah
that's true right if you really like
something you're not going to get bored
with it I mean there there are some
parts about coding that are kind of
boring
but usually those are things that you
could probably just write a function to
do for you alright so depending on how
you approach it it may or may not be
that that boring right Robert says I
think boredom comes from too much
studying when people apply the knowledge
they've obtained and try to troubleshoot
that's when you won't be bored anymore
yeah that actually that makes a lot of
sense like actually building something
is usually like never boring like trying
to just read through material and learn
that can be boring so I do recommend
learning programming mostly by actually
building things
and only reading about something when
you need to use it that seems to be the
way you'll you'll learn a lot more
quickly that way and you'll build cool
stuff while you're doing it Nicko asked
what's python used for robert says
python use for basically everything yeah
i mean put you can do a lot of different
stuff with python in particular python
does seem to be used for machine
learning quite a bit but it yeah it's
also I mean you could build any anything
with Python really like any backend
stuff really it says what IDE to use for
coding this is Visual Studio code
Nikhil says but why he said not for
Android well Android so like certain
platforms you use a certain language so
like Android uses Java or Kotlin ILS
uses Swift if you want to do a WordPress
website it's built with PHP so like
certain platforms have already been
built around a certain programming
language right if you wanted to build an
entirely new mobile operating system you
could certainly build it in Python right
but since the Android operating system
is already built in a certain way then
it only runs certain code right so
there's probably some way to build an
app for Android in Python and then have
it converted to stuff that the Android
operating system can handle probably
Java right hopefully that makes sense
alright and that's it that's the oops
actually this shell says what is the
Spring Framework
I don't really know I've heard of it but
I have no idea what it is I can't even
remember where I've heard it now I am a
mean or a mean I'm not sure how to
pronounce that it says thank you for
everything Jesse from Morocco oh you're
welcome thank you for for
Morocco's one of the places that I
really would like to visit I've seen a
lot of cool TV shows about like people
taking trips to Morocco and it seems
like a really really cool place cool
like culture and food and everything so
anyway maybe one day I'll get a chance
to go to Morocco I've actually never
been outside of my home country so we'll
see so you've ever make it out Rutledge
says how did you learn all this stuff
online courses books any suggestions
yeah mostly online online courses really
and a lot of what I've learned has just
been like I'll get a job or a client and
I need to do a thing and so I look up
how to do it and I just any resources I
can find I learned from those whatever I
can do to make it work
Okubo says thanks so much Jesse just
making up my mind to learn react reacts
Mac Oh cava from Nigeria oh thank you
for saying that up eh I'm glad maybe I
had a little impact on on helping you
decide if you want to learn react so
good luck Nico says thanks to reply
you're welcome all right okay I'm gonna
okay [ __ ] is it Jorge from Panama let
me know if I'm pronouncing that wrong
but hey how's it going all right yes I'm
gonna go now I'm starting to get really
hungry and it's definitely been time for
me to leave the office so I want to get
home and celebrate my my daughter at
Gemma's birthday she I'm pretty sure she
just turned seventh it's so yeah I want
to get home and hang out with her and
anyway I really liked hanging out with
you all and doing some coding and I know
it's been a while I'm gonna try to be
better about streaming more often this
week's just been crazy with all the
meetings and stuff so anyway hopefully
this will probably be my last stream of
this week hopefully next week upstream
or I'm gonna be off on
Monday it's it's a national holiday here
so I won't be in the office working but
I think I don't know it might be another
week before extreme now that I think
about it because of the holiday yeah but
I'll see you at some point next week and
you know I'm always on all the different
social media and networks and stuff so
you could reach out to me there or you
know maybe you'll see some of my posts
and stuff so I'm definitely active on
Twitter and on Instagram the most I'm on
all the like a lot of the other like
snapchat Facebook all that other stuff
I don't really post that much though but
LinkedIn so if if you want to chat just
find me somewhere and I'll do my best to
get back to you as soon as I can all
right cool all right yeah so I'll see
you all next week sometime until then
have a great rest of the week and
weekend and thanks again for watching